intermittent fasting 13 to 15 hours lose
weight you want to increase growth
hormone you want to increase
testosterone you want more ketones for
better mental clarity 13 to 15 hours
autophagy is where your brilliant body
looks within and it says okay no food's
coming so i better be a better version
of myself those cells start to repair
they kick out viruses pathogens they
kick out metals they kill cells that are
going to turn into cancer cells like you
at 17 hours of fasting you go into this
crazy repair phase at 24 hours your
whole microbiome reboots and you get
stem cells in your guts if you've been
on birth control
antibiotics mouth toxicity even removing
breast implants all of that destroys the
microbiome so throw some 24-hour fast at
it 36 hours you're burning more you
start to really go after stubborn fat 48
hours and you reset dopamine pathways in
the brain and then 72 hours you reboot
your whole immune system
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to the pretty
intense podcast and the episode today is
epic on the show is mindy peltz you can
call her dr mindy
she's a functional health expert she
specializes in women's health fasting
detoxing the conversation today had the
most amazing articulated flow ever it
was there's so much in this for men and
women most of the time we talk about
women but just understand that anytime
we talk about women in the episode
that uh if you're postmenopausal and
you're not having your cycle anymore
it's basically a men's cycle so
this will still apply to men too um
although we do talk a lot about women
and we talk a lot about women in their
cycle it's just an area like most
studies are done on uh on men and so
having data on women is just magic and
it's so helpful and in the episode we
just talked about you know what are the
pillars of health and
what uh what kind of fasting windows you
should have and at what point in the
month if you still are in your cycle we
talk about coffee we talk about wine and
chocolate we talk about so many
different things that can really help
with your health and help with your
hormones and at the root of all of it is
are these sex hormones must must listen
to even all the way to the very end this
is something that will serve you for the
rest of your life i am very very
confident about that and that there is
so
much benefit in fasting and i'm about
ready to have to go do myself a long
fast because she talked me into it so
please enjoy this episode uh hit
subscribe if you like what you're
hearing and please let us know in the
comments what you think and what more
you want to hear about thanks
thanks for doing this how are you today
i'm awesome how are you thanks for
having me i'm staying at my parents
house so if there's like dogs or a
children a child that happens to run by
or a parent like just
bear with us for a second it'll feel
like my home so no worries oh gosh
really do you have a bunch of kids uh
well they're ground now 22 and 19 so
they're launched and uh so we're like
official empty nesters learning how to
live in a quiet home but it was like a
party for 22 years oh my god well i mean
i wouldn't have guessed that you had
kids that old so fasting really does
work
thank you thank you
i'm doing everything i can to slow the
process down of aging
i mean how long have you been fasting
like was there some impetus to it did
you have a health problem or a weight
problem like what was it that made you
go hey i'm just gonna
not eat then oh well let's find the
science now yeah it's it's such a good
question this is what i always say is
like i really should not have been the
poster child for fasting because i was
the person that carried snacks with me
everywhere i got up and had breakfast
every morning like the fear of going
without food because i would spiral my
moods my energy was
most my life that's you huh yeah yeah so
so i you know i i just landed into it to
try to find a solution for my hormones
so at about 40 the the the general story
is that at like 40
i was in great shape i had goals of like
fitting in my skinny jeans and i needed
a a number on the scale to be a certain
way and i wanted a certain energy and i
hit that
and at 43 i was like a hot hormonal mess
i was not sleeping i had you know night
sweats i had um i had
brain fog like my whole body felt like
it had gone off
so i was trying to figure out what had
changed because my lifestyle hadn't
changed i had my workouts were the same
my food was the same like everything was
the same
so when i went to go look for what
happens to women when they go into their
40s i realized that one of the things is
estrogen naturally starts to go down and
so as it naturally goes down we become
more insulin resistant and as we become
more insulin resistant new things show
up and
new symptoms show up and so fasting can
help the mental clarity fasting can help
the weight loss fasting can help balance
estrogen like once i started to look at
all of that
i was like whoa this is a tool that i
need to check out
so what is the relationship between
insulin and estrogen because i just
understand insulin to be sort of like
the catch net for your blood sugar going
up like when you're you eat your blood
sugar goes up insulin comes in to bring
it down right yeah yeah and so what is
the correlation with estrogen then yeah
so okay so here's the way that i like to
explain it is we have a hierarchy of
hormones so at the bottom of the
hierarchy are the sex hormones
progesterone estrogen testosterone like
they're at the bottom which means that
they least important or foundational
does that mean yeah you could say
foundational you could say foundational
but what you'll see when i explain the
top three is like they are so
manipulated and influenced by insulin
cortisol and then oxytocin sits at the
top the best way to look at this is when
our sex hormones will respond to changes
in insulin so here's a great example
pcos pcos is the number one hormonal
problem for women
and it is directly connected to insulin
resistance you take a woman with pcos
and you get her insulin under control
you get her detoxing those two things
because phthalates also plays a big part
into pcos and you can change pcos i've
seen it a thousand times but you got to
get her insulin sensitive because she
needs to be insulin sensitive to get
those foundational hormones under
control here's the trick is that above
that is cortisol so you take a woman
who's like super stressed out and she's
trying to get insulin sensitive and she
can't because cortisol forces us to hold
on to more insulin hold on to more
glucose to become more uh in that
fight-or-flight stage
and then above that is oxytocin so
oxytocin is the hormone that makes
everything better and it balances
cortisol it balances insulin and it'll
balance those sex hormones so when we're
looking at to answer your original
question when we're looking at hormones
they're flipping moving targets like you
know right as you are experiencing yeah
so you get estrogen in balance and then
all of a sudden you go on a three to six
month like
binge with your food and insulin gets
off and now estrogen is going to start
to tank
you get cortisol under control you
decide to change your lifestyle and
maybe you're you're doing better and all
of a sudden progesterone starts to
balance out so each one of these
hormones influence the impact on the
other ones which is why they are so
hard to balance because they're always
changing
yeah well what are the main factors to
balance them then like if you were to
have buckets like how many would you
need and what would they be yeah like of
like food fasting emotional stability
like what are those things yeah so i
really say there are five things that
women have to do so the first is fasting
and here's here's the way i approach
fasting and it's so different for women
than men so that's the first thing i
want to point out right i have a lot of
questions about women versus men okay
for sure this is this is a huge one
because when i first learned fasting at
43
what i noticed was my mental clarity
went through the roof like at my 3
o'clock dip in the afternoon gone my
sleeping was good my night sweats went
away like all these really weird
perimenopausal symptoms cleared up just
from the first one which is fasting and
it's because i finally got insulin under
control
for and we can go into this later but
for women estrogen loves when you fast
progesterone doesn't progesterone it
like because
right because it's
progesterone right and we need
progesterone to feel like a normal human
and not kill everybody so but
progesterone is so influenced by
cortisol
so when we do too much fasting we start
to tank cortisol or we start to elevate
cortisol and tank progesterone so as
women and we can go into this in a
moment as women we need to know when to
fast and when not to fast
that and men don't have to think about
that right men can just fast whenever
they want and from what i understand
women can fall into the men category
once they finish menopause and they are
out of their cycles well said okay amen
yes which is is awesome and
let's talk about
the menopausal perimenopausal woman
it's nor
a healthy age to go into menopause is
about 52 somewhere between 52 and 55.
okay most women and this was me at 4 30
at 43
many women i shouldn't say met most many
women are going into full-on menopause
at 43 and mid-40s
and
when you do that what happens now is you
set yourself up for the diseases that a
lot of women get later on cardiovascular
disease
the breast cancer breast cancer ovarian
cancer
so
with fasting what i'm trying to help
women see is that when you learn how to
fat when to fast for estrogen and when
not to fast for progesterone and you
learn like a rhythm with fasting and you
get yourself insulin sensitive you will
prolong your period which is fabulous
and it'll put you into menopause at the
appropriate time to prevent disease okay
well how do we do it
there you go so that that's that's
fasting the um the other four ones that
i think every woman needs to think about
and i don't know if you know this one
this one blew my mind is that we're not
meant to eat the same way throughout
every day of our cycle
yeah to some degree because i um have
become friends with elisa vidi who wrote
in the flow and woman code and because i
had cycle issues and my whole story
doesn't is is its own thing but anyway
it drew me into the book and so i then
started to learn sort of like a more of
a rhythm to like certain foods that help
with estrogen follicles progesterone
like and and and just allowing your body
to get into its site into a rhythm and
so there's the sort of like four cycles
of food per month obviously that
correlate with
correlate with which part of the month
you're in right which is let's just stop
there for a moment like i know in my 13
year old gym class where i was taught
puberty that there was
nothing
talked about like you might want to carb
load a little more before your your
cycle starts you might want to do a
little less carbs when you actually your
cycle actually starts like
nobody taught us that no no no no
there's like there's no real teaching on
the fundamental things that really
affect you in life like you know your
cycle uh relationships
self-improvement like your emotions your
trauma
right there's so many things we don't
learn about in school like we're being
taught like proofs and geometry and
[ __ ] we'll never ever need right but you
know we came to real life and we're like
i don't know
it's a no man's land so thank you for
sharing this stuff with us right right
well so this is my big once i figured
out how to fast and eat around my
hormones that's at 43.
i was like wait a second why did nobody
teach this to me at 13 and why didn't i
learn this in my 20s like where was this
education missing which is so such a
huge part of why i'm just trying to wake
women up to help them see this
which is amazing so if there was a quick
way to say like what those sort of
eating patterns are is that easy enough
to give us some tips on
phase of your cycle what i've done is i
created something called the fasting
cycle and i took a 30 day period and i
mapped out when a woman's hormones were
coming in and what food and fast we can
time to it
we even by the way can time our exercise
i don't know with the lisa yeah yeah
there's food exercise there's emotion
sex like every category gets covered so
every category i mean all the biohacking
cold plunges like are we supposed to do
those all the time these are all
questions i've tried to map to the
hormones so
so this is the way it works on day one
we have this plummet of all our hormones
so the first day you bleed and you
probably since you've talked to alyssa
you know um that our hormones plummet
now those first couple of days estrogen
is going to start to ramp back up and
over the next 10 days estrogen slowly
builds
estrogen loves
us to be insulin sensitive so when after
the first couple of days are over with
our cycle like into day three we can do
keto we can go into longer fasts all of
that is only going to benefit estrogen's
production so
i always think like we have women in our
community that they flip and love
three-day water fuss have you done one
i've done 36 hours
oh awesome
okay so you're you could do a three day
it's we're gonna talk about hunger at
some point in time
spiritual experience
so yeah at three so these women you know
they people love to do the 36 48
three-day and because it makes them feel
so good
but it's easier are you saying it's
easier than two
it's way easier yeah way easier good
point
so you that first 10 days longer fast
less carbs that's going to help estrogen
then we go into ovulation day about day
11 to 15 well you've got estrogen at her
peak you've got
testosterone coming in for the first
time let's just talk about that how
biologically amazing we are that
testosterone comes in during ovulation
that is that is super smart of our body
we want to get it on yeah right exactly
as we're we're
we're supposed to during ovulation which
is like there's a tip for the men of the
group uh so but then we need to help
break down those hormones so during
ovulation less fasting
i even find people who are doing keto at
that time not a great choice because
testosterone needs a little more glucose
in our system
so more of like working on your
microbiome we have a whole set of
bacteria that break estrogen down break
our hormones down so you want to bring
carbs back up during ovulation and but
nature's carbs this isn't go sit on the
couch and eat a you know box of pizza
and a tub of ice cream so and so you
want to bring your carb load up and fast
a little less
then we come out of
our ovulation window and we have another
dip of hormones we can fast again then
day 16 we go keto again 16 through 18
we're golden but then progesterone
decides to come in around day 19
and that's the moment we need to chill
out a little more we need to bring
glucose up because here's the thing
about progesterone in order to make
progesterone your brilliant body
actually becomes more insulin resistant
the week before your period
so that it can make progesterone it
purposely blunts insulin from getting
into the cell so you can have more
glucose to make progesterone
that we should have been taught so
there's a reason you crave carbs there's
a reason you want to kind of go inner
and you don't want to be like like
pushing your workouts you don't want to
be raising cortisol you don't want to be
fasting and that all happens the week
before
oh wow
wow yeah that's amazing i mean this is
like
this will change
if this was taught and this is something
we implemented i can't imagine the
benefits in the long term so
we're a generation away from it
okay i like that yeah exactly um okay so
we've talked about so what are the first
two categories for the most important
things so we had we just talked about
fasting fasting number one number two is
number three is a little bit of what i
mentioned with the gut so
we have these set of bacteria that break
estrogen specifically down but they also
break our hormones down so what i'm
finding is that so many women have been
on birth control for so long they've
been on multiple rounds of antibiotics
and their microbiome is a hot mess
so you can give that woman hrt you can
give them bioidenticals but if they're
not taking those those key hormones and
breaking them down in the gut
it's not going to work
so the third one is let's focus on foods
that repair the gut and there's three
categories of them the polyphenol foods
the probiotic and prebiotic foods
and you know if you look at like the
average person eats one and a half
servings of vegetables a day
and
that's we need like six seven servings a
day we're just not feeding our
microbiome so that's number three is
really get into more more green leafy
vegetables are the best but even things
like hemp seeds chia seeds um seeds and
nuts if they're done right can be really
good for the microbiome even dark
chocolate
wine can have
wine could it can affect the microbiome
positively
right
so there's we don't it's not deprivation
it's it's knowledge and knowing what
you're doing to support your hormones so
polyphenol foods
probiotic and prebiotic foods are a
hormones gift because you can break that
down what what are polyphenol foods
so so polyphenol foods think of them
like
here's how i think of the microbiome
it's like a pet inside your gut that
needs to be fed
and those three foods i talked about all
have qualities that feed the microbiome
polyphenol foods have a high antioxidant
um capability that will nourish the
bacteria so they grow
uh some of the greatest ones are like
what i just said the
wine really is some of the greatest
i make wine so like this is like singing
to my right right now right and i'm not
saying that women should just go out and
start pounding bottles of wine but
you know dark chocolate not a serving
sauce
it's that's gonna have to be a personal
choice but uh it also lowers cortisol so
that's nice yes which is emotions which
we can talk about at some point okay so
that's the third one what's another
what's the next uh fourth one is detox
so
what happens when you go into your 40s
is that the ovaries go into retirement
and they start to take like a 10 to 15
year like decline and they're like okay
i'm out i'm gonna stop making sex
hormones and i'm gonna hand that over to
the ovaries or over to the adrenals
which we'll talk about in a moment
but in that decline our hormones in our
40s are going
up and down like we'll be high one day
we'll be low the next and that wild ride
signals to the body to release toxins
so wherever you've got toxins lead is
stored in the bones in your mouth i know
you just did an explant like
awesome job by the way thanks incredible
i know it's not crazy it's like a silent
epidemic in my mind basically
yeah absolutely so what happens to women
in their 30s is all those toxic issues
don't really show up but in your 40s
they're like nope we are coming out of
the tissues and when they come out they
go up into the brain they go into the
hypothalamus and pituitary and they
start throwing off hormones and now
we've got women that are like i was like
43 40 years old 44 years old and really
having depression anxiety
and you know all the symptoms we get
with menopause and we ne we label it
perimenopause put it in a little little
bucket sure and we just call it aging
and say it's just part of life
and give it no give it no nothing to do
but just sit there and let women suffer
so
toxicity is huge for women in their 40s
everybody's going to have to learn to
detox
um is this something that can be done on
a regular basis or should be like let's
say you test and you know your levels
are okay and
is there a certain protocol like are you
saying they should kind of you should
kind of keep up with it like there's a
certain amount of sort of sweating and
binders that you should do just on a
regular basis versus sort of maybe like
three months like hardcore cycles with
dmsa and all the stuff that it takes to
truly chelate yeah um or
what are you what are you implying it
sounds like you've been detoxing i've
done a i've done uh i've done nearly a
full cycle of chelation um i had i've
kind of phased through a few different
couple of different doctors and so i i
got pretty far through the round first
round um i think i had a couple cycles
left of it um but i mean i just tested
my medals again and i'm fine so yeah i
saw that that's amazing yeah really
crazy and that's a whole nother
interesting topic about so the first
thing to to toxicity is you remove the
toxic source so right that's what you
did
good job but for some people it's living
in a moldy home sure
other people it's mercury in their mouth
sure and hereditary lead lead's
hereditary right so yeah that's just
something you got yeah so that was my my
heavy metal was lead and when i went and
tested myself my sister and my mom
you could actually see mom's is the
highest older sister is the second
highest and i was yeah so it gets passed
down yeah
right and then i went back and looked at
like when i i had some reading
comprehension uh challenges as a child
and i went back and looked
lead actually slows down uh your ability
to to take words and turn them into and
lock them into your cognition in your
brain
and i'm like oh my gosh
they labeled me as like not smart i just
had lead
oh my god yeah so
and so
the thing is is you've always had that
but what you're saying is is that once
you kind of get into your 40s when the
hormones sort of
paths shift and they're not as as
efficient as they used to be
they come to light that's right that's
right and i think that's the big thing
for women to realize is
when we get into our 40s there's this
shame and guilt that happens because all
our old tricks don't work anymore we
used to be able to right we used to be
able to out exercise everything we used
to be able to diet our way out of
everything that does not work anymore so
and a large part of that is because
these toxins come out at as the hormones
shift
and to answer your your other point when
you go to detox
it's not as simple as you're probably
learning as just throwing chelators and
binders at it you've got to support your
detox organs so your liver your skin
your lymph your gut your brain like all
of these organs are working on detoxing
you so making sure you're supporting
those you got to then pull it out of
your body first because the third and
the last step that changes everybody's
life is pulling it out of the brain
if you don't and you start to just pull
it out of the brain it gets dumped into
the body and the body's not ready so it
has to be very strategic yeah it can be
dangerous you don't just like go sweat
and then take a handful of binders and
or buy some dmsa or whatever key later
you can find on the internet it's
dangerous that's
well that's what i i
watched so much about that because my
mercury was so high it was a hundred and
seventy when it was originally tested on
the on the um um uh provoked urine test
and so
what is it now
uh the last i think when i was checked
it was four some four four basically
crazy and and it was detox plus explant
implants number one probably the most
important thing because it's like a
perpetual sort of like feeding of the of
the toxic metals but um i did nearly a
round of chelation
and then last summer
while i was training for the boston
marathon uh sweating which i know
sweating is really important i was also
sauna
and taking binders um in
in in
conjunction with that to get rid of
things so yeah i i i mean i i did all
those things yeah it was a rough summer
last summer yeah
yeah so i and that's the thing about
detox is there's no one way to do it
there's your way to do it and when we
don't know where you're stuck or what
your pathways are doing and
just being patient and methodical and
having somebody
guide you through it is make will make
all the difference yeah yeah okay great
detox and then what's the fifth most
okay the fifth one this is my favorite
and you should interview this woman on
your podcast
it's called uh rushing woman syndrome
and i didn't come up with that her name
is dr libby weaver
and she wrote a book many years ago
about what happens when women but what
happens hormonally to women
when they're in that rushing lifestyle
which was totally me
and it's all about how cortisol when
cortisol comes in
we all of our hormones start to go
astray like you could you could take
your life right now and all the
wonderful things you're doing if you put
a bunch of stress on there and an over
scheduled life
it you're just ramping up cortisol and
you're slowing down your healing process
so we've really got to mind cortisol so
much more especially when we get in our
40s
because those hormones are already going
into some interesting places so if we're
like rushing from thing to thing if
we're stressed out all the time and then
that woman tries to exercise like to the
extreme you try to fast to the extreme
all of these things start to make our
sex hormones go out of balance so
because science strengthens fasting is
as fasting as a stressor too
yeah um so what happens i'm just curious
um is there a is there a certain point
in time um
when i'll tell you my story at the end
is there a certain point in time where
you you sort of activate that cortisol
enough that it shuts down
oh like a like an adrenal fatigue cause
i had my i did the dutch test yeah and
the dutch test it my cortisol spiked in
the middle of the night and i woke up
and it went down from there i woke up
and it didn't come up it just kept going
down yeah which is indicative of adrenal
fatigue right well so adrenal fatigue is
yeah so yes and adrenal fatigue is
really a connection from the
hypothalamus pituitary and the adrenals
so what we have to remember with all
endocrine organs they don't work in
isolation they work as a team
so when let's use you as an example as
toxin a toxic load is building up we're
getting the hypothalamus and pituitary
is not working they're not hearing the
messages from the adrenals as much and
then you know put you look at just look
at what you did for a living cortisol
and adrenaline had to be at its highest
and so you were constantly calling on
those adrenals over and over and over
again
and so your whole system just finally
crashed and was like
exactly
i hope you're going to use that video
clip that was too good definitely we're
going to clear it let's let's screenshot
that jen
that was good but yeah i mean you you
when i look at what you're doing now is
you're
you're repairing your body from
what you did for a live for a career is
you gotta
rebalance that cortisol to be able to
rebalance the other hormones that's
super beneficial all right let's talk
like specifically now about um fasting
or was there anything else you wanted to
mention about adrenals i know you had
said something earlier that we'll talk
about that is there anything any tip is
it just basically you know what are the
main factors that um sort of tap the
adrenals yeah yeah a lot i mean life
everybody's life i think i think what
i'm learning i will say at 52
is that i'm learning that there's times
to go into sympathetic fight or flight
and that's how our body was meant to be
and it's okay we're not trying to like
just sit on the side of a mountain and
meditate we want to be able to go in but
then when we sit down and we're not busy
we want to be able to relax
and so there there should be this sort
of seesaw with sympathetic
parasympathetic nervous system but what
i'm seeing with so many women this is
what i experienced i'm sure you
experienced this as well
is there's so much fight or flight so
often that that becomes our driving
nervous system we don't have a
well-tuned parasympathetic nervous
system
and so when we come to fasting
what happens is we try to use that same
type a like i'm gonna rock this fast
sure and all we've done is put ourselves
more in fight or flight so
when we go to repair those adrenals
we've gotta also repair the nervous
system we've gotta detox and we have to
learn life balance which is the hardest
so maybe to kind of close the loop on
just because we'll get more into details
of fasting and different things but like
is there a recommended amount of fasting
length fasting periods for
um because we kind of you kind of
articulated this sort of um flow
of how a month goes for someone in her
cycle and um basically the most sort of
the lengthiest lengthiest
term of fasting could be used
for men and women that are
post-menopausal correct right so what
would that sort of what would those
windows look like as you went through
your cycle
through the cycle yeah so let let me go
one step before that because then i
think it'll help people understand where
it fits in the cycle so based off the
science that i've seen and what we see
in our resetter community we do
different fasts every month so and then
people report back what they're
experiencing both men and women
and um what we see is that there are six
different length fasts that people can
benefit from and i'll go through them
very quickly intermittent fasting 13 to
15 hours great i mean that's what so
many people are doing
and what it's really great i mean the
research is all i mean you don't have to
go far to see amazing research there but
if you want to you know lose weight you
want to increase growth hormone you want
to increase testosterone um you want
more ketones for better mental clarity
13 to 15 hours is amazing
17 hours we start to to
trigger something called the tophagi
autophagy is where your brilliant body
looks within and it says okay no foods
coming
so i better be a better version of
myself and so those cells start to
repair they throw they kick out viruses
pathogens they kick out metals they kill
cells that are not gonna that are gonna
turn into cancer cells like you at 17
hours of fasting you go into this crazy
repair phase
at 24 hours your whole microbiome
reboots and you get stem cells in your
gut so if you've been on birth control
antibiotics mouth toxicity even removing
breast implants all of that destroys the
microbiome so throw some 24-hour fast at
it and now you're repairing you're
getting that repair 36 hours you're
burning more you start to really go
after stubborn fat
48 hours and you reset dopamine pathways
in the brain so you start to experience
more joy and then 72 hours you reboot
your whole immune system
wow i do not know
a supplement a drug
anything that can accomplish that like
fasting
that's why i love it
wow how often would you recommend
more extreme ones beyond the 13 to 15.
because to me that's where i fall i sort
of fall in the 12 to 15 even 16 is kind
of hard to get to
um i usually just like use 12 for sure
um but then the longer ones
oh and we're gonna get you to do a
longer one you're gonna love it so
here's here's the way it works is that
if you look i look at the cycle like a
circle
on the first part of our cycle like day
one to day ten
um again any of those fasts i talked
about are great yeah
ovulation period you really 15 hours is
good but we don't want to stimulate
autophagy during ovulation because what
can happen is a lot of those metals can
get redistributed into the brain into
the body
um some people have worse detox symptoms
so i like to keep the fast for women
under 15 hours during ovulation
after ovulation those four days
afterwards you can go into if you want
to throw a three-day water fast at it
great
and then the week before your period no
fasting which is
really hard because
yeah like eight-hour like it doesn't
matter just like
not above 13 you really want to keep it
under 13.
so if 13 is easy and you're like i can
just do it it's super simple go for it
but
what you don't want to do is raise
cortisol
so for most people 10
8 10 hours of fasting is going to keep
cortisol where we want it okay okay what
about um what about where we slot
workouts in with this cycle and um
should you work out fasted
uh yeah does that fit in you know that's
this is this is a controversial uh topic
i i mean i i literally like it it's
something in my head that's a
controversy because i'm like fasting is
a stressor work out to stress her like
i'm trying to take care of my adrenals
i'm trying to take care of my hormones
trying to not slow metabolism down
trying to not slow my thyroid down like
there's so many things that i'm thinking
of and i'm like wait but there's so much
benefits from it and they talk about
there being a lot of really good
positives with like
training in a fasted state so yeah so
where do you stand
yeah so this is what i found is again
the front half day one i'll just use the
days because it's easiest it did we
start in the hormone world we throw all
these fancy terms around ludial and
follicular and i think for the
layperson they're just like i don't know
what that means so um i like to make it
a little more clear day one to day 10
you can
run a marathon you can
take on a new crossfit class you can
up your workout you're going to do great
during ovulation
you've got testosterone
and so use testosterone to your muscle
advantage so yeah so start upping your
strength training during ovulation if
you want to do more cardio during those
first 10 days great more strength
training during ovulation then when you
come out of ovulation again we have that
weird little dip of hormones you can go
back into pushing your workouts and and
really you could do more hit training
you could do more cardio you can kind of
do whatever you want and then the week
before your cycle
stop pushing it yoga
pilates go for a hike
so we when you look at when you work
with a trainer or you create your own
workout plan it's usually done on a
weekly basis like okay
i'll run on monday i'll strength train
on tuesday
exactly for women we should do it on a
monthly basis we shouldn't do it on a
weekly basis because if we map it to our
hormones like if you're trying to build
muscle
flip and do it during ovulation you've
got testosterone to help you really
power through that
but we don't look at it that way as far
as i know okay what about um where
coffee fits in i always have to ask
about coffee because i love coffee yeah
i did i stopped coffee for two and a
half months last summer when i lost my
cycle when my like my lymph nodes were
so swollen and i could feel them getting
worse when i drank coffee like after a
cup i was like oh i can feel it so i
mean like i was obviously a pretty high
load of toxicity in my body but yeah
yeah but um but i'm very curious about
it and then also maybe adding in a
perspective on um
you know adding fat to your coffee and
if you know kind of being in a fasting
mimicking state is
beneficial or not and maybe the
difference between weight loss and
autophagy and cellular health and
longevity
okay let's start with coffee and if i
forget the rest you'll have to yeah i i
remember
obviously i want to know a lot of things
no i love it it's such it's i think
there the whole world can benefit from
fasting not just women um you know we're
talking about women but obviously men
rock fasting
but what happens is we get into the path
like you were saying like there's all
these amazing things i can do for my
health and we get in that path and then
we get stuck and we just push the health
tool out and go ah it didn't work for me
but there's a rhythm to all of this so
with coffee my first question is were
you doing clean coffee do you know if
you were doing like chemical free mold
free coffee i always make sure i drink
like
mold free clean organic like you know i
mean i think an easy one to probably go
to would be like a bulletproof coffee
i'm like brand bulletproof brand because
you know it's advertised and it's
supposed to be
low mold and toxicity so yeah so i've of
all the research i've done on coffee i
it the only time coffee doesn't do well
for us is when it's toxic
so
uh not to name any
any names of uh coffee shops but uh you
know the like the mainstream ones
are are there chemicals in a cup so
every time you're drinking that you're
giving yourself a toxic dump that kind
of coffee i do not advocate for
clean coffee is a fasters like dream
because when we take a good clean cup of
coffee there's and we put like mct oil
in it put some grass-fed butter if
that's your jam
put in some i put like raw cream i'll do
like not organic raw cream so you're
getting probiotics and enzymes in it
it's a bit like a meal and it won't
spike your blood sugar it typically
doesn't pull you out of a fasted state
and what happens is it'll actually help
you make ketones quicker
the coffee itself can actually put you
into a tophagi quicker
so
there's not a lot wrong with coffee for
fasting when you get those ketones it's
ketones go up into the brain and they
kill hunger so now you wake up and
you're like oh
i was gonna go till noon today fasting
but it's nine o'clock and i'm hungry
what am i gonna do
have a cup of coffee with some mct oil
in it you could put a little bit of raw
cream in it not this is not coffee mate
you're not putting like
toxic creamer in there
and all of a sudden wait wait 20 30
minutes and you'll see that your hunger
goes away because it moves you into that
fasted fat burning state much easier
right and when you say raw because i've
been i've been sort of watching a lot of
different things talking people talking
about um like unpasteurized raw cheese
and milk and things like that but it's
very hard to get it's illegal in states
it's right
i mean don't worry you can buy
cigarettes but you can't buy you know
raw milk right is that what you mean
yeah
yeah so raw so what happens when we
pasteurize milk is we kill all the good
in it
so if you walk into your let's say
grocery store and all of a sudden you're
like oh i'm going to go organic
pasteurized i heard that you know i
don't want the antibiotics and the
hormones that are in that milk so i'll
go go organic well that's awesome
because you're not getting the toxic
load but you're still putting a dead
food into your cup of coffee
when you go raw you've got the
probiotics you've got the enzymes in
them you put it in your in your coffee
you're feeding your microbiome you're
breaking down any you know whatever food
you're going to eat later that day it
now becomes a health food how do we why
is it
why is it controversial
well maybe
why a lot of things are controversial
because people learn how good they are
for you and there's some conspiracy
against muting us from our pure
potential i don't know
so
you know amen i am high fiving you on
you know synthetic painkillers are fine
but psychedelics aren't right like
there's just like uh you know stuff from
the ground so it's right you know i have
a lot of opinions on that but so how do
you get it like because i mean i'm in
indiana with my parents right now and i
was like oh i want to get some raw dairy
and um we were like googling it and
looking it up and you can't get it i was
at a farmer's market last weekend and i
asked a farmer about raw dairy and he's
like it's like illegal you know you have
to pasteurize it could have some bad
bacteria from unlike so basically the
sourcing matters and you know so how do
you get it like what if you're in a
state
that it's i mean because almost all
states i think it's illegal the the
company yeah well i'm in california so
it's we seem to be able to get it here
so at
california's very own that was the one
that we saw california has um looser
rules on it so yeah can you ship it in
kind of like is it a california company
where you can order some raw yeah it's
called raw farms
and uh you can look them up online if
you have trouble finding them just let
me know i'll send you the link
they are amazing all their all their
dairy is raw and they have everything
from um you know cream which is what i
use in my coffee in the morning to kefir
so and they have like two golden kefirs
so they have turmeric and uh cinnamon
and kefir has like trillions of good
bacteria in it when it's not pasteurized
so what's the difference between milk
and kefir
it's it's more sour milk and it has more
good bacteria in it wow is it a
different sort of pumping process from
the i think it's what they do i think
it's afterwards i think they ferment it
afterwards they like
i think really what they do is they
leave it out so that those good bacteria
start to become sour yeah
so it's like sauerkraut
okay okay sauerkraut milk interesting
the things we do for health
okay great so then what do we do like
you know there's again this is another
area that i've read a lot about about
breaking your fast and how to do it and
you know what what's the best way to
break your fast so thank you for asking
this one because
one thing that i noticed as we started
to fast the world was that people would
get excited about their fasting window
and they would either do one of two
things they would just keep fasting
they're like i'm just gonna fast because
i feel like a superwoman or superman
and then when they ate they didn't know
what to do so they were fasting too much
not sure what to eat or there was the
boomerang people those were the people
that were like i made it to 20 hours i'm
doing so well and then yeah and then
they would go to and start eating down a
pizza so
when you're in a shorter fast i have
come up with three different ways that
we should break a fast when you're in a
longer fast there's a four-step process
that i've been teaching my my got it i
was curious if there was a difference
between a short and a long one yeah
right so so briefly uh the three types
are protein
probiotic
and prebiotic foods so the i call them
the three ps um or you can break it with
a fat and and i'll explain the
differences of those three
people who are trying to build muscle
and this is really important you want to
break your fast with protein and this
goes back to your autophagy question
when we go into fasting states we go
into autophagy autophagy is repair
autophagy is breakdown autophagy is the
opposite of a process called mtor
mtor is where we like bill when we want
to build muscle we want mtor you
stimulate mtor by eating
almost anything but protein will
stimulate the production of the mtor
pathway and help you build muscle
autophagy will clean and lean you out
they're both beneficial
so when we work out and this kind of
ties back to your workout question when
we fast we work out in a fasted state
and then we come in with a protein rich
meal you're now starting to build muscle
like nobody's business because you have
fasted and leaned yourself out you've
gotten written rid of that extra glucose
and now you stimulated the primary
mechanism to build muscle and you pair
that with it with a strength training
workout and you you give me a 65 year
old woman and i can show you how to
build muscle on her and coffee is it and
coffee before you go you can do coffee
too yeah
so that's so that's protein i think
that's my favorite um
what about the difference between a
fatty and a low-fat protein because i
used a continuous blood glucose monitor
last year too i did every i should
everything i could think of um and it's
amazing how
chicken can raise your blood sugar but
then
you know
fat just it's fat's like the only thing
that doesn't and so there's also like a
certain order of the way you eat can
that can really help with your blood
sugar so yeah if you're breaking it with
protein what kind of protein do you
recommend yeah um i'm curious did you
notice what it did to your protein or
when you did protein protein what did it
do to your glucose
if it was a fatty or protein sometimes
nothing um but if it was chicken that
was a little bit of a more a bigger
spike um
it wasn't as much as certain sort of
starchier carbs
but but yeah protein did it like chicken
seem to the less fatty the meat the more
blood sugar spike
so i'll be interested now that you've
been on you're on such a good health
path that if you notice protein actually
makes your blood sugar dip
because it when you have healthy
mitochondria and you feed it um the
proper amino acids from different
proteins you actually should see your
glucose dip when you eat it like fat
yeah
what it's crazy so do any amount of
protein
yes any kind of like i'm talking about
like regular ground beef that has you
know 17 grams of fat per serving versus
chicken with you know zero or one like
any protein it's yeah because it's about
the amino acids so
when you so let's look at all the
proteins um chicken's gonna have a
different profile of amino acids than
turkey like turkey has more tryptophan
in it and grass-fed beef is going to
have a different amino acid profile and
when you're eating a variety of protein
you're nourishing those mitochondria and
you're giving them amino acids that they
need to function well so your protein
too yeah it's in variation so when we go
to a farmer's market where we look at oh
here's goat oh here's bison oh you know
here's buffalo we try to get all the
different types of meat so that we get a
different amino acid profile
yeah and then that fuels the
mitochondria which balances gives you
more energy heals your body but you know
all the things that you're you're trying
to do with your health really boil down
to you're trying to repair your
mitochondria
exactly so when we break our fast with
protein is it that we start with the
protein on our plate first or is it that
we eat protein and then we wait a little
bit and then we eat whatever meal you
know respectfully in health that we
choose to how how is the what is the
strategy yeah so you want to start with
protein and then you can minutes later
you can do you could do something else
you can also mix it like with something
so one of the things i love to do is a
couple of hard-boiled eggs and um or
soft-boiled and put them over an avocado
um half of an avocado with some
sauerkraut and sprinkle some hemp seeds
on it
and some sea salt and that's a typical
right typical break fast meal and now
i've gotten
the protein i i've gotten the fat i've
fed my microbiome
and
i can do that sometimes at noon and not
want to eat again until seven
o'clock what about the strategy because
i feel like i've heard different things
when it comes to carbohydrates and not
only you articulated throughout the
month
where the best times to eat more
carbohydrates are
but what about in the day because
you know i've heard night time helps
with sleep but then i've also heard that
eating at the beginning of the day so
that you use it and you have a purpose
for it
and less as the day goes so what do you
believe there with carbohydrates yeah oh
this is another really good one um so
again what i want i hope as everybody's
listening to this that you start to
understand there is a unique approach to
your health for you
so when we say nutritional
statements like what i'm gonna say here
in a moment you have to realize that
ultimately it's what you're trying to do
with your health
if you're trying to lose weight
when melatonin comes in around sunset
your eyes will register the red light of
the sunset and will start to make
melatonin and so that you can become
sleepy when melatonin comes in you are
more insulin resistant so
you if you're trying to lose weight and
you have a bowl of pasta at eight
o'clock at night that's gonna be stored
as fat more than if yeah than if you had
it at three in the afternoon
so for weight loss it's not great
okay let's say you're trying to sleep
you're like i don't care about weight
loss i'm pretty insulin sensitive i just
want to sleep well okay if you go don't
have carbs at dinner
and you have just protein tip oftentimes
what happens is you're waking up at two
or three in the morning because your
blood sugar dips and at two or three in
the morning it hits this alarm and all
of a sudden your adrenals go wait
glucose is going down cortisol come in
and you wake up at two
and your heart's racing and you can't
get back to sleep
so the night time is tricky depending on
what you want to do
the morning time is always earlier in
the day is better for carbs because you
get to you get to use that glucose
so yeah
what about um i know these are nuanced
questions but i have an expert so
um something like um
you know there's a lot around having
maybe a little bit of carbohydrate
before you work out i've totally watched
things about keep it fasted but then
i've also seen stuff about you know the
benefits of having a little bit of
carbohydrate and so i can sort of
probably assume that while you're in
those sort of first 10 days in that
little dip window after
after ovulation that you know you
probably don't need to worry about that
but during those other phases is it wise
to have a little bit of carbohydrate
before you would go exercise yeah and
again it's what you're what you're
trying to do so if you're going into a
really intense workout and you want
performance you want to kick butt in
that workout you would want to have a
little bit of carbohydrate before you go
in
but no but the right carbohydrate i'm a
big fan of nature's carbs like some
fruit or
then as opposed to like a bagel that
would be a good of course yeah a better
choice
not as tasty yeah we haven't ate bagels
since the 90s and i don't like any of
them i would go rollerblading with my
girlfriend and we'd go rollerblading for
a couple hours and then of course we'd
stop at you know big apple bagel and we
would have two bagels because we were
ultra healthy and then you know dinner
we'd have grilled chicken and then we'd
have all the fruit in the whole wide
world and maybe even some white bread
with fat-free italian dressing to dip it
in like you know the things that we used
to do right right well believe it or not
a lot of people are still doing it the
what a lot of people are doing is
oatmeal i feel like the whole world
loves oatmeal for breakfast oatmeal or
oat milk both both well oat milk yeah
both but oatmeal the world loves oatmeal
and my blood sugar
was sky high with a little oats with a
little bit of oats yup i mean just sweet
potatoes and oats were my thing i could
eat popcorn or even chips and um rice
and those were fine but like
man the oatmeal oatmeal was a danger
zone yeah yeah that there's it's
interesting because what i've noticed in
just talking to so many people that are
applying these principles is their exact
opposite of all the trendy things and
what we've been taught so like oat milk
why can i get why can i get oat milk at
starbucks but i can't get raw milk
like
oat milk is no good for your most
people's blood sugar you would i think
if we slap cgm's on most people they
would see that oat milk and oatmeal
spike their blood sugar yeah so we have
to start questioning like
these trends like oatmeal looks like the
new soy milk you know it is like what
were we doing right just like the bagel
just like mom was running down the
driveway you know in the 80s with the
bagel for breakfast we don't do that
anymore i i do wonder today well of
course in those days we thought it was
the smart thing to do and there's things
we're doing right now that we think are
the smart things to do and we're going
to realize some of them aren't yeah
and i wonder which ones those are going
to be oh i can i can tell you like i can
tell you exactly
we have to go back and look at how our
cave friends lived how did they lived
off the earth they hunted they fasted
they did feast famine cycling
this is how the human body was meant to
be treated we were not meant to sit on
our couch and go oh my god i'm hungry
let me let me pick up my phone and
doordash and have food brought right to
my front door
from some processed place with the bad
oils
that is literally killing humans so if
you want to know how to eat go back and
look at how our cave friends did it also
when i think about animals like i just
thought about a cow grazing they're big
right
a gorilla right just grazing and eating
grass and things like that and then
you've got like a lion who has to go and
get its food and there might be some
feasting times right but then there's
some famine times until you find your
next you know deer running through the
woods and uh well in the jungle and in
the desert for where lions live
your
next
um but yeah you think about the kind of
even even from an animal perspective and
the ones that graze versus the ones that
are feasting famine with food and it
does kind of tell a story
it's
when you go back and look at and really
think about the trajectory of humans
we are literally living in the same body
as our as our cave ancestors
but we now have computers and phones and
doordash and pantries and refrigerators
we are treating this human body
completely different than it needs to be
treated so and we actually uh i just put
out uh of a fasting book that's coming
out at the end of this year
for women and i was doing some research
on it and i found that there was
actually a gene
that
became prevalent in humans because of
the cave man cave woman days
and it's called the thrifty thrifty gene
and basically what happened is that we
become became
genetically slanted for fasting because
in order to survive long periods without
food the only people that could survive
that in the cave ancestor days were the
ones that were able to genetically fast
longer because sometimes they had to
fast like a month genetic adaptation
total genetic adaptation okay that gene
is in us now so what what's happening
with doordash and eating all day and
the comfort levels that we all are in
with this this crazy life of ours is
we're going against our genes
and that is building disease so a lot of
theories around diabetes right now is
that not only are they so high because
of the horrific food we have
but people are eating all day and
they're going against their genetic
profile
hmm crazy right
yeah i mean it's just again just lacking
the accurate information um
you know go eat i mean i feel like there
was some
thing where it was talking about wake up
and eat your wheaties or eat your sort
of cereal in the morning and it had
something to do was then isn't there a
story about that oh yeah it came out
what is it yeah okay so there's two
things it's kellogg's and and i
you know no disrespect to the kellogg
family but but he actually did two
things wrong
so that and it all came down into the
cornflake uh cereal so the first thing
that he did is he
came up with the slogan breakfast is the
most important meal of the day
that slogan
was to promote his corn flakes
okay i have googled it i have looked to
see it is breakfast the most important
meal of the day i can't find anything
and if you don't believe me go
the listeners go google it
there's nothing that shows breakfast but
we walk around in 2022 going breakfast
the most meal of the day we
i've said it i've said it like i'm
guilty and i care about my health like i
i mean it's a that propaganda was
solidified yeah right okay this second
one and now i recently heard this on an
on a on an interview somebody was
interviewing me that his he put toxins
in do you know this
no i thought it had to do with a wife
and it had to do with something about
women yes yes okay yeah it has to do
with testosterone that he purposely did
created the chemicals and the way that
corn flakes were were manufactured was
to to
affect negatively testosterone to make
people less uh desiring sex
to tank their libido
why would a man do that
i just heard that one last week because
i was being interviewed on another
podcast and they were saying
uh we were talking about the breakfast
is the most important meal of the day
and this woman got so into it she's like
i'm gonna google and find out you know
where i can see that and then she found
that statistic
and uh you know it's it's just
i mean corn flakes like
there's so many mothers out there
serving corn flakes to their children
thinking that
rice krispies cornflakes you know
cheerios yeah
it's crazy so
we just we have to wake up and question
everything i mean this i love what
you're doing on your podcast like we got
to question
everything question me i always tell
people this is why i put the put
research out there this is why i have
900 videos on fasting on youtube
question me i'm not talking about 700 of
them
hopefully i've been entertaining enough
oh you're super informational super
informational you you've had the best
information so far i feel like on women
in fasting and cycles and things like
that i started adapting some of that
stuff
what about how to keep your metabolism
and your thyroid working because i feel
like in my understanding is that you
know as your weight drops and as if you
eat less essentially there's your body
adapts to a sort of lower thermogenic
sort of
set point so how do you keep those
things high
while
shrinking and eating less and less often
such it's such a great question and if
you've watched 700 of my videos you know
you know this already but basically we
have to redefine metabolism so let's
start with this
you do not speed your metabolism up by
eating all day long there is no evidence
on that so this six little meals a day
to speed up your your metabolism it's i
don't know if i can swear on your
podcast but it's where all that all you
want oh i haven't thrown down any
f-bombs i'll i'll see what i can do
there but it's [ __ ] [ __ ] down yeah
it's literally
[ __ ] you do not speed your
metabolism up by eating little meals all
day long here's what your metabolism
does you have two of them
one is going to get energy when you eat
and we call this the sugar burner system
i don't like the name sugar burner
because everybody goes oh i don't eat
sugar anytime your blood sugar goes up
you are operating from that system okay
you have another system which is a fat
burner system and this is where your
body instead of making energy from the
food you eat it's making energy from
burning fat and this is how you know you
are in that system is the presence of
ketones
so when ketones go up now we know
that we have tapped into that system
now you were made to switch in
and out of these two systems
it's that simple so if you've never
fasted before if you've never gone into
a ketogenic state you have deprived your
cells and your brain of 50
of the fuel that it needs to thrive
so when we look at food we've got why i
like nature's carbs is because it's got
fiber in it so your blood sugar doesn't
go insanely high it goes a little bit
high
and that gives you quicker access to
move into the fat burning system
so if you've never gone more than eight
hours without food and you're not
looking at the the quality of the food
you're eating
this system you don't even know it you
haven't accessed it once you access it
you're gonna be a flippin superhuman and
that's why i think so many people are
falling in love with fasting is that
they all of a sudden found a new fuel
source that it works so much better for
them
yeah
yeah amazing crazy right yeah so there's
just no there's just
there's no magic it's just like do
fasting properly is there a certain
cycling you should do or anything like
is there anything that boosts the
metabolism or boosts your thyroid
function or is it really just like
like how do we how do we keep it all
working because like my thyroid was
[ __ ] for the last few years yeah
yeah well it's going to be better now i
would i would think it went up within
two weeks of surgery being over and
that's just because that's when i tested
it was two weeks after right
so okay so let's i want to go back to
the thyroid tubi and then i'll talk
about the variations um because there's
a big myth that
fasting is harmful to the thyroid
i want to point out that fasting is not
calorie restriction
so when you look at the studies done on
t3 specifically or t4 and t3 both but a
lot of t3
plummeted
with
calorie restriction
not time restriction
so
when you eat
if you're gonna fast when you eat eat
don't eat less eat less often it's and
then you are actually nourishing the
thyroid so on the thyroid thing that is
so fascinating is the studies show
calorie restriction um will start to
bring down t3
and if you do that in combination with
time restriction yes now you've got
yourself a thyroid problem but here's
what the study didn't point out because
the studies are very nuanced
is that if you do time restriction
eating and then you power up with the
proper nutrients when you refuel
you actually get more t3 you actually
are able to get more thyroid hormones so
it is the the in and out of fasting and
fed state that starts to br prime the
metabolic pump heals the organs gets
your your hormones back on track we
can't we can't villainize fasting it's
just not understood enough because
that's how we're designed to be got it
what about um just the last probably
question about like the fasting windows
like i understand the actual
intermittent fasting window but then
once you're in your feeding window
um is there a reason to have gaps
between because i have you know i've
tried to keep a few hours between or
like four hours but then all of a sudden
i'm like the strategy's off and now i'm
kind of hungry but i need to like oh so
um can you is it does it matter within
for gut health or for
anything like that
not necessarily here's the way i would
look at your 24-hour cycle is that
there's a an eating time and there's a
fasting time okay so the way that i
approach my day is i'll go okay how long
am i going to fast for so like this
morning i've got i'm on several
interviews so by one i'll i'll probably
think about opening up my eating window
once i open that eating window up
then i eat when i'm hungry this is not
deprivation so
if i if i eat and then i'm hungry two
hours later i'll eat again
so it takes that like rigidity of
dieting out of it
it's like just once you open the window
you can eat just eat good quality fit
got it okay great okay well i want to
close up with a video that i saw you do
recently about the benefits of community
and emotions and just how that plays
into our reality because these are all
things that you know everything we've
talked about so far is mechanistic you
know it's food windows timing
hormones things like that but
a thing lost in our overall health that
we forget about a lot of times i think
is this emotional state and the people
we're surrounded by and and how we feel
so
you know maybe just your sort of you
know perspective and studies on the
benefits of and and the and the and the
downfall when this environment isn't
correct yeah yeah oh my god you're going
right at my heart so thank you for
asking me that question because
i feel like especially in the last
couple years we've been so isolated and
we're not we're not looking at community
as a healing tool
and it it almost i mean a positive
community would be amazing that's
definitely you want to hang around
people who are synergistic with the way
you want to think but just being around
humans creates this oxytocin benefit and
we get a little bit of oxytocin right
now in this conversation but if we were
doing this live both of our oxytocin
surges would be so high
and you need lots of oxytocin to do
exactly what we've been talking about to
bring cortisol down when you bring
cortisol down you're going to bring
insulin down when you bring insulin down
you're going to balance your sex
hormones
so when we look at how women try to
balance their hormones we come at the
sex hormones without thinking about the
impact oxytocin has on all the levels
above those foundational hormones
so what one of the things that i talk a
lot about is a fasting lifestyle and
that there are four pieces to it one is
what do you want to do because that's
the most important thing not everybody's
fasting path is the same
the second is very your fast third is
vary your foods and the fourth is do it
in flippin community
when did health become a solo journey it
shouldn't be a solo journey i can get on
a three-day water fast and do it by
myself and maybe have an introspective
spiritual
you know health experience or i could do
it with a group of people who are
supporting me cheering me on i turn
around and cheer them on and now that
same three-day water fast has more of a
hormonal effect on me because i did it
around people this isolation thing [ __ ]
has to it has to stop and if what i'm
really excited about is if you look at
what happened after the 1918 pandemic is
that we went into the roaring 20s
what happened in the roaring 20s is that
we got social we started the speakeasies
started and i'd like to point out that
women cut their hair they shorten their
skirt they started drinking they started
smoking
the flapper emerged after that pandemic
so what i'm really focused on right now
is that for women specifically i call it
the empowered woman we need to empower
ourselves connect with each other
not just for fun for our hormonal
benefit and that needs to be sung from
the mountaintops in my opinion well you
just did
thank you
i think that's a that's a perfect way to
to end is just to reaffirm that the
importance of that and you know we have
had such trying times the last couple of
years but i firmly believe that you know
through adversity and challenge
there's an awakening there's a there's a
there's a there's a shift it's we're
just kind of dealing with polarities
we're dealing with
sort of balance and when it goes so much
one way it goes back the other way right
well said yeah it's time for the
paradigm to go go back to hugging
touching
loving connecting like that we need that
more now than ever so yeah so grateful
thank you for having me yeah thank you
gosh what a
densely informational fascinating last
hour thank you so much thank you thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today i hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the subscribe button